monsieur gratter chaleur magasin je
pense à moi qui me champagne a voulu
profiter des rabais du vendredi fut
débrouille martineau elle a acheté une
dizaine de meubles qu'elle a payé près
de 7000 $ ces neuf comme ça
lambo ici exposés d'être accrochés 6 2
dans le sofa la table à manger sur les
treize meuble acheté sept sont
endommagés j'ai payé le plein montant
pour du neuf je m'attends à recevoir du
neuf mais c'est pas ça tu me champagne
vu un échange ou un remboursement
mais les démarches s'éternise appel au
sein de sa clientèle l'agresseur le fond
envoie des photos je mette autant
ensemble survie - là haut on a peut-être
un 40e on a une bonne semaine ouvrage
lakhdar dans un message vocal bruit
martineau renvoie la balle aux
manufacturiers
sylvie de bellefeuille est avocate chez
option consommateurs
est ce que l'entreprise peut attendre de
voir comment la manufacturier vous ragez
en théorie les deux sont responsables
la limite doit être vraiment je voudrais
plus la patience du consommateur à
travers tout ça selon le professeur yami
grégoire brouille martineau cherche à
minimiser ses coûts au risque de
déplaire à la clientèle
les politiques mises en place par la
firme c'est très évocateur parce que ça
reflète vraiment la culture de
l'organisation
personnellement je trouve que les
politiques de broue martineau sont très
très loin des bonnes pratiques mais dans
leur secteur la patience de kim
champagne atteint ses limites elle
décide de poursuivre aucun représentant
de la société mère n'a répondu à nos
messages mais elle a réagi et la
poursuite de keane champagne
l'entreprise propose d'annuler la vente
c'est-à-dire de reprendre les meubles et
de la rembourser mais l'offre arrive
trop tard ils essaient de dédommager
mais au bout de la ligne ça fait huit
mois je suis au même point que jo en
quinze jours vers mes choses qui me
champagne veut être dédommagée pour tous
les inconvénients qu'elle a subi
oui martineau pour le meilleur et pour
le prix
pour la paix ici jean luc bouchard
réseau canada montréal